- Legal Eagle is coming in loud and clear
thanks to Ting Mobile.
Before President Trump's
photo op at St. John's Church
in front of Lafayette Square,
which resulted in peaceful protestors
being gassed with chemicals
and shot with rubber bullets,
he appeared in the Rose
Garden behind the White House
to outline his response to the protests
that have roiled this nation.
President Trump threatened
to take dramatic action
to quell the protests,
including invoking the
Insurrection Act of 1807,
which allegedly would allow
him to deploy the military
to crack down on protesters and rioters.
President Trump did not officially
invoke the Insurrection Act,
but he did use his unique
authority within the district
to make a serious show of force.
In recent days,
for reasons that should
be relatively obvious,
people have debated how much authority
the president has to use the military
for civilian law enforcement purposes.
And in addition to the Insurrection Act,
you probably heard people
mention the Posse Comitatus Act
and claim that the president actually
doesn't have authority to
invoke the Armed Forces
in riots and protests.
Well, I'm here to
deliver the sobering news
the president actually
has a lot of authority
to use the military against
the American people.
But whether he can do it
and whether he should do it
are two completely separate issues.
(epic music)
Hey, Legal Eagles.
It's time to think like a lawyer
because I can personally
confirm that there are
a lot of American troops
operating on American soil as we speak.
And by the way,
I started my research for this video
by going to what I think is by far
the best resource for
national security law.
And that's a blog called Lawfare.
It's simply, bar none,
the best resource for answers
to national security law questions.
You can go there at lawfareblog.com,
I highly recommend it.
So let's start with the
Posse Comitatus Act.
Does it stop the president
from using the military domestically?
Now it's easy to confuse
the Insurrection Act of 1807
with the Posse Comitatus Act.
In fact, you'll often see people say that
the PCA actually bars the president
from using the military
in domestic matters.
And there's some truth to it,
but it's largely false.
Section 1385 of Title 18
of the US Code states,
"Whoever, except in cases
"and under circumstances
expressly authorized
"by the Constitution or Act of Congress,
"willfully uses any part of
the Army or the Air Force
"as a posse comitatus or
otherwise to execute the laws
"shall be fined under this title
"or imprisoned not more
than two years, or both."
Now a big part of a
lawyer's job is analyzing
the text of laws and judicial opinions.
And you'll notice that this
language provides a bar
unless there is a specific act of Congress
or something in the
Constitution that allows it.
This is one of those situations where
the exception predominates the rule.
And generally, the Posse Comitatus Act
prevents the military from participating
in traditional law enforcement activities.
However, Congress has enacted many,
many exceptions to the PCA
to allow the military to assist civilian
law enforcement agencies
in enforcing the laws.
For example, the Department of Defense
can provide some support
to law enforcement agencies
battling drug crimes and organzine crime.
The military may also defend
their own bases and property.
It's one of those instances where
the exceptions tend to swallow the rule.
It's kinda like the rule against hearsay.
Sure, there's a general rule against
hearsay being admissible in court.
But, frankly, there are so
many different exceptions
that it's actually the rarity
where you can't get the hearsay
admitted into court as evidence.
But the biggest exception to the PCA
is the Insurrection Act itself,
so let's talk about that.
The Insurrection Act of 1807
actually refers to five
pieces of legislation
that are found in 10 USC,
Sections 251 through 255.
The law sets forth several scenarios
that a president may use
to justify deploying the
military domestically.
Now, before the president can invoke
the Insurrection Act, he quote,
"Must first issue a proclamation
"ordering the insurgents to
disperse within a limited time."
If the situation does not resolve itself,
the the president may
issue an executive order
to send in troops.
How, it's important to note
that the Insurrection Act
actually dates back to a time when
municipal Police Departments
didn't really exist in this country.
And so, it made sense
that there would be times
when the federal government would need
to send military personnel to help out
with state or local issues.
Now, given that in the modern era,
ever state and every municipality
has a Police Department,
one might question the utility of having
the Insurrection Act
remaining on the books.
Now, the oldest section of
this law is Section 254,
which was enacted in 1792
to give George Washington authority
to call forth the militia
to repel invasions,
suppress insurrections,
or enforce the laws.
Congress was initially reluctant
to grant even Washington this authority,
so they required that he would first need
to give insurgents a warning to disperse.
And although President Trump
has explicit threatened
to invoke the Insurrection Act.
- If a city or state
refuses to take the actions
that are necessary to
defend the life and property
of their residents,
then I will deploy the
United States military
and quickly solve the problem for them.
- To date, it's not clear
that his speech qualifies
as a proclamation required under this act.
Section 251 of the Insurrection Act
deals with federal aid
for state governments.
It combines two laws from the
earliest days of the Republic.
One was a law used to suppress
the Whiskey Rebellion of 1794.
This was an uprising of
farmers and distillers
who protested a federal whiskey tax.
After years of protesters
tarring and feathering
tax collectors and destroying property,
President Washington was given authority
to call forth the militia
upon the request of a governor
or state legislature.
The second part of this
law was enacted in 1807
at the request of President Jefferson,
and allows the president
to call up a standing army
as well as the militia.
Which brings us to Section 252,
which regards to the use
of militia and Armed Forces
to enforce federal authority.
Section 252 was enacted in 1861
at the request of President Lincoln,
to increase presidential authority
to use the militia and regular army
to suppress insurrections
and enforce the laws.
This law was the legal basis
for waging the Civil War.
And the law allows the president
to use federal troops
on his own initiative
and act on his own judgment
without having to wait for
the request of a governor.
And, in fact, you're seeing
a lot of governors on TV
recently stating that they are not
going to request federal
troops or federal aid
under the Insurrection Act.
The thing is, for most
of the Insurrection Act,
it doesn't require gubernatorial approval.
That brings us to Section 253,
Interference with State and Federal Law.
In 1869, Congress added section 253
at the request of President Grant
to empower him to use federal troops
to suppress the Ku Klux
Klan during Reconstruction.
Section 253 states, quote,
"The president, by using the
militia or the Armed Forces,
"or both, or by any other means,
"shall take such measures
as he considers necessary
"to suppress in a State any insurrection,
"domestic violence, unlawful
combination or conspiracy,
"if it, one, so hinders the execution
"of the laws of that State
"and of the United
States within the State,
"that any part or class of
its people is deprived of
"a right, privilege, immunity,
"or protection named in the Constitution,
"and secured by law,
"and the constituted
authorities of that State
"are unable, fail or refuse to protect
"that right, privilege or immunity,
"or to give that protection;
"or, two, opposes or
obstructs the execution
"of the laws of the United States,
"or impedes the course of
justice under those laws."
And you can tell by the plain
text of this language that
that is incredibly broad authority.
And that in a situation where
you have peaceful protesters,
and rioting and looting going on
at the exact same time,
that it's not surprising
that someone might use
the unlawful activity as a pretext
to curtail the lawful activity as well.
Now, originally there were
two fairly large limits
on the use of military personnel
by invoking the Insurrection
Act by the president.
The first was that the
president had to get approval
from a federal judge.
The second was that the Insurrection Act
could be used until Congress
came back into session,
and then had to approve
the use of the military.
Now, those two restrictions
on the Insurrection Act
sunsetted out and no
longer are part of the act.
And no longer act as a check
against the use of military personnel
under the Insurrection Act.
So when has the Insurrection Act exception
been used to Posse Comitatus?
Now, although the Insurrection Act
has not been used frequently,
presidents have invoked
it to enforce the law,
especially when racial
equality is at stake.
In 1957, President Eisenhower called on
the US Army's 101st Airborne Division
to safely escort nine black students
into Little Rock Central High School
after the Arkansas governor, Orval Faubus,
had called on the Arkansas National Guard
to stop the students from
integrating the school.
President Kennedy invoked
the act in 1962 and 1963
to send federal troops to
Mississippi and Alabama
to enforce civil rights laws.
In 1967, President Johnson sent
the 82nd and 101st Airborne
Divisions to Detroit
to quell riots between
police and residents
after Martin Luther King
Jr. was assassinated.
And in 1992, President H. W. Bush
responded to a request from
Governor Pete Wilson of California
to quell rioting in Los Angeles
after the acquittal of
the four LAPD officers
who brutally beat Rodney King.
- There are 3,000
national guardsmen on duty
in the city of Los Angeles.
And let me assure you,
I will use whatever force is
necessary to restore order.
- So in modern times,
the presidential use
of the Insurrection Act
has generally been used to enforce
civil rights, and integration,
and racial equality
rather than the opposite.
And it's generally been used in ways
that most people would
find unobjectionable,
at least in this day and age.
And sometimes that use
of the Insurrection Act
was explicitly against the
wishes of the state governors.
For example, Governor Faubus
had improperly used the
State National Guard
to disregard federal court orders,
regarding integration of students.
And in that example,
he certainly did not want
the federal government's assistance.
In fact, that ran completely
contrary to what he wanted.
Governor Wilson, on the other hand,
did ask for help from President Bush.
And the other instances also involved
quelling of riots that
were explicit responses
to racial injustice.
And there's probably one
other historical example
that is incredibly relevant.
And that was the federal
government's response
to Hurricane Katrina.
When the levees in Louisiana broke,
the state and federal
government were slow to respond
to the enormous logistical challenges
and humanitarian crisis.
President Bush considered
invoking the Insurrection Act,
but the Department of
Defense was concerned
that Americans would be reluctant
to see the military in that role.
And at the time the military
was fighting two wars,
and eventually Congress
amended the Insurrection Act
to clarify the circumstances
that would justify
the use of Armed Forces.
There is now language in the statute
that lets the president use the military
to restore order and
enforce the federal laws
if there is a natural disaster,
epidemic, or terrorist act.
Though, ultimately,
the Bush administration
decided not to invoke the Insurrection Act
in support of humanitarian
efforts regarding Katrina.
And it's probably important to talk
about the distinction
between norms and laws.
The law itself has been pretty
broad for a very long time,
but it's revealing that
presidents have been reluctant
to invoke the Insurrection Act.
That is a presidential
norm, a societal norm,
but it is not written into the Act.
And you can see how a broadly written law
that has been used in some instances
where no one would object,
and probably other instances
that were closer to the margins,
can be used for good and ill
depending on who is upholding
the norms and who is not.
And the Katrina example is important
because it reveals two concerns
that normally come up
when there's a situation
requiring a national response.
And that also involves the difference
between norms and laws.
First, the American people
have traditionally been
very wary about military
operating on US soil.
This, in turn, has made the military wary
of being deployed for civilian matters.
And there are very good policy reasons
that should probably be pretty obvious
as to why you don't want a military
doing law enforcement activity
and why you want a strong separation
between a military that's trained to kill,
and a police force that is
trained to serve and protect.
And second, the Bush administration
had a significant debate
about whether to invoke the act.
Members of Congress weighed in
and so did all 50 governors.
Under normal administrations,
both Democratic and Republican,
there's a decision-making process
where the president
hears from stakeholders
about the pros and cons
of using the military.
That doesn't mean the
president lacks the power
to use the military or enforce the law.
On the contrary, the president
clearly has the discretion
to involve the military
in civilian affairs
under these different acts,
even if the governors don't ask for help.
but rather it signals that,
at least in modern times,
we've had presidents who thought
about what the governor's might want;
how the people might react;
and whether a military response
would actually make things worse.
And it's hard not to think
about the historical example
of Caesar crossing the Rubicon,
that sometimes the norms involving
the lack of participation
by the military and domestic affairs
or at least crossing
the Rubicon into Rome,
that that norm exists for
a very, very good reason.
And it's also probably worth pointing out
that the Posse Comitatus Act,
in conjunction with the Insurrection Act,
contemplate that the president is going
to faithfully execute the laws.
And that, on that basis,
the president probably
has a lot of discretion
to use the military to stop riots
in the name of enforcing the laws,
because we have a lot of laws out there.
And it's hard to not think about this fact
without examining the context
of what actually happened
when the president mentioned
invoking the Insurrection Act.
That while he was giving his
speech in the Rose Garden,
that he or Bill Barr gave orders
to clear out the protesters
in Lafayette Square
so that the president
could get his photo op
at Saint John's Church.
To clear a path for the
president's impromptu walk,
the US Federal Park Police used
OC gas, pepper sprays, rubber
bullets, and flashbangs
on a crowd of peaceful protesters.
All of this happened
before the 7 p.m. curfew.
And, of course, the right to protest,
to peaceably assemble,
is part of the First Amendment.
This is part of the freedom of expression
that all Americans enjoy.
Protests are a way of
life in Washington, DC.
Which is to be expected,
this is after all the seat of government.
But it doesn't mean that
President Trump's actions
on Monday were necessarily
illegal in the strictest sense.
Over the last several decades,
courts have allowed government
to make more restrictions
on the time, place,
and manner of protests.
As long as those restrictions are
what's called content neutral.
And you can imagine how some of these laws
conflict with individual citizens' right
to First Amendment activity,
to petition the government,
to peaceably assemble and to protest.
There are, in fact, many statutes that
make it clear that protesters cannot
block access to federal buildings,
or destroy private property,
or stop the president from
going somewhere he wants to go.
But you can also imagine
how some of these laws
might be used as a pretext
to quell First Amendment
expressive activity.
And one of the things that made
President Trump's actions
so incendiary is that
he wasn't on his way to the Capitol
to meet with Congress,
nor was he doing anything strictly related
to the business of being president.
Instead, he just had an impromptu photo op
that appears to be used for
his reelection campaign,
that wasn't planned out,
and specifically conflicted
with the protesters
who were already there and
were already protesting
peaceably using their
First Amendment rights.
But that's the difference between norms
and things that are written into the law
And perhaps we've just been
lucky that, prior to now,
we haven't had such a bumbling example
of a pretext used to evacuate people
exercising their First Amendment rights
in front of the White House.
And the same goes for the use of troops,
and military and federal officers
throughout DC and the rest of the country.
Even President Nixon never placed soldiers
at the foot of the Lincoln Memorial,
blocking the American
people from accessing
one of its most significant memorials,
which we have seen that the
Trump administration has done.
And it's been a long time
since all of Lafayette Square
and such a significant portion
of downtown Washington, DC
has been completely locked
off from protesters,
or even tourists.
I participated in the
Women's March in 2017.
There were tens of thousands,
if not hundreds of thousands of people,
who were allowed to walk right
in front of the White House.
And even that wouldn't be available
based on what's going on right now.
And, in fact, in a direct
historical parallel,
when mass protests erupted
after students were killed
by the National Guard
at Kent State University,
then President Nixon left the White House
and met with protesters personally
at the Lincoln Memorial.
This surreal event eventually led to Nixon
creating a formal study of campus unrest
during the Vietnam War.
But because of Washington,
DC's unique position
as a federal district,
rather than a state,
and because of its disenfranchisement,
the federal government has authority
to use federal troops and
military police officers
in the limits of Washington, DC
in a way that they actually can't do
outside of the district.
So if it sounds like President Trump
has a lot of power, he does.
Presidents, in general,
have a lot of power
to use the military for different ends.
But as things stand, it's up in the air.
It's not clear that the president
has actually invoked the Insurrection Act.
Secretary of Defense, Mike Esper,
has voiced his opinion that
the president should not, in fact,
invoke the Insurrection Act,
and should refrain from
using the US military
to conduct law enforcement
and anti-riot actions.
- The option to use active duty forces
in a law enforcement
role should only be used
as a matter of last resort,
and only in the most urgent
and dire of situations.
We are not in one of those situations now.
- So it's not clear how long
he's going to be the Secretary of Defense.
But you can imagine that
if the Secretary of Defense
is urging the president not
to use troops in this context,
that it's not surprising that people
are going to protest the
use of this kind of force,
in addition to protesting
the police brutality
that we've seen throughout the country.
But, unfortunately, if
you're out there protesting
this use of the military
and police brutality,
there's a chance that you
might be illegally arrested
for your First Amendment activity.
And if you are arrested
and you need to make
your one phone call to get your lawyer
to get you out of jail,
then at least you can use Ting
Mobile and save some money.
And as a bonus, the call
with your civil rights lawyer
will be super clear.
(chuckling)
God.
Ting Mobile is a different
kind of mobile provider.
With Ting, you only pay
for your actual data
and services you use at
the end of the month.
And because you're paying for
only what you actually use,
Ting customers pay on average
just $23 per month for one device.
And Ting provides great LTE coverage,
because it uses the T-Mobile, Sprint
and the Verizon network.
So you get the benefit of
three massive networks wherever you go,
which can be important
when you've been unfairly
detained in federal jail.
And with Ting, you can
use almost any cellphone,
including the newest
iPhones and Pixel phones.
And you can use the same phone number
you're using right now.
There's no contract, overage fees,
or any other carrier tricks.
You just pay a fair price
for the talk, text, and data
that you use up every month.
And Ting has award-winning
customer service.
Because they don't have any
brick-and-mortar stores,
they pour all of their resources into
their phone and online support.
If you have any issues,
you can just give them a call
and you'll immediately
talk to a real human being.
and they might be able to
hook you up with a lawyer.
(chuckling)
With Ting, especially if you're
around Wi-Fi all the time,
which most of us are,
considering we're working from home.
I wonder if federal jails have Wi-Fi?
You'll end up paying way
less than you do now.
Of course, some people
should pay $200 a month
for unlimited data if they're
nowhere near their homes.
But if you're surrounded
by Wi-Fi all day long,
you might be paying
hundreds of dollars more
completely unnecessarily.
And Ting gives you the option
to pay only for what you use.
So if you go to LegalEagle.Ting.com,
you can use your last bill to compare
just how much you would save.
And Legal Eagles will get a $25 credit
by going to LegalEagle.Ting.com
that could cover your entire first month.
And since there are no contracts,
you can try it for a month.
No strings attached.
Again, all you have to do is
click the link in the description,
or go to LegalEagle.Ting.com
and get a $25 credit for
whatever service you want.
Plus, clicking on the link
really helps out this channel.
So, do you agree with my analysis?
Do you think that we should amend
the Posse Comitatus and
Insurrection Act laws
to make it harder
to use troops on American soil?
Leave your objections in the comments,
and check out this playlist with
all of my other real law reviews
talking about the crazy stuff happening
with protests, and COVID-19,
and basically all of the news.
There's a lot of it.
So, click on this playlist
and I will see you in court.
Hopefully not literally.